[Música]
[Aplausos]
quiero que se tomen unos segundos y se
imaginen el medio ambiente
y mantengan esa imagen en su cabeza
ahora quiero que se imaginen a ustedes
que son dónde están
se cuentan esas dos imágenes tienen algo
que ver una con la otra están
relacionadas
sí sí felicidades porque desde las pocas
personas que me ha tocado que logran esa
conexión siempre que empiezo la
conferencia hago esta pregunta porque
desde que me dedico a todo este camino
profesional en el aspecto ambiental me
ha dado cuenta que la causa de todos los
problemas ambientales actuales en el
mundo es la falta de conexión justamente
de estas dos cosas medio ambiente y ser
humano entonces no los juzgo porque yo
era exactamente igual de hecho yo a los
15 quería ser modelo
después quise ser diseñadora de modas a
los 17 me inscribí en mi carrera y
estaba todavía entre mercadotecnia
entra en mercadotecnia finanzas y
negocios y me metí a mercadotecnia
porque mi familia es libanesa y me
encantan las ventas y dije sos para mí
eso es buenísima
y así
me di cuenta en un momento de mi carrera
me entró como un momento de lucidez con
un vídeo que se llama la historia las
cosas que me hizo preguntarme que iba a
vender el resto de mi vida que iba a ser
durante todos esos años
para crear el mundo no
entonces les quiero hacer una pregunta
ustedes saben de que estamos compuestos
pero me refiero no a brazos piernas el
ser humano de que está compuesto
únicamente tienen idea
bueno si no sabían somos 65% oxígeno con
una combinación de hidrógeno nitrógeno
carbono y todos los elementos que se
puede imaginar combinados atómicamente
maneras diferentes que es lo que ustedes
conocen como órganos tendones piel
huesos y también estas combinaciones
generan 65% agua grande que está
compuesto la atmósfera
o la tierra la tierra es 47 por ciento
oxígeno y todo lo demás de diferentes
combinaciones de otros elementos
la atmósfera es nitrógeno y oxígeno y
todos los otros elementos ven la
similitud somos exactamente lo mismo que
lo que estamos parados que lo que
respiramos entonces cuando ustedes dicen
necesito aire para respirar no necesitas
aire para respirar tú eres el aire que
respiras entonces por eso lo necesitas y
cuando dices necesito comer no necesitas
comer eres los nutrientes que sacas de
la comida entonces si podemos ligar esas
dos cosas nos podemos dar cuenta que
absolutamente todo incluso en este salón
lo que están viendo todo es naturaleza
procesada el piso es madera que si
ustedes pensaron en un bosque al
principio era un árbol y ese árbol
estaba en la imagen que se hicieron si
pensaron en el mar
aquí todos tomamos agua cierto y el 80
por ciento de los mexicanos tomamos agua
embotellada entonces en alguna parte del
mundo el mar se evaporó por el ciclo
hídrico natural del agua si es una nube
esa nube se movió por el aire y en otra
parte del mundo llovió esa lluvia hizo
una corriente esta corriente hizo un río
que llevó un lago y en alguna parte de
ese proceso una empresa agarro ese
recurso y embotelló y es embotellado se
lava que usted están tomando en este
momento entonces absolutamente todo está
relacionado
no sé si ven en la película de avatar a
mí me encanta pero esa conexión que
sacan no es ficción es real y el
problema es que no nos damos cuenta que
el mundo no está para servirnos somos
parte del lecho nosotros lo necesitamos
entonces en un amigo que siempre me dice
que el mundo hoy en día es mejor en
todos los sentidos menos en el medio
ambiente y yo siempre le pregunto y ahí
empiezan como los debates y dicen más y
toda una polémica no le pregunto cómo
puede ser eso a ver explícame cómo puede
estar mejor en todos los aspectos menos
el medio ambiente si hasta el dinero
si este papel es un árbol si es de
plástico es petróleo los bancos están
construidos todo lo que se puede
imaginar todo lo que compramos
medioambiente entonces cómo puede estar
mejor
entonces sabiendo esto que sigue no o
que ya sea que yo soy medio ambiente
todo el medio ambiente
sigue saber que absolutamente todos los
problemas ambientales en el mundo hoy en
día desde la contaminación del aire a
los rendimientos del fol de los pueblos
el calentamiento global absolutamente
todo eso está directamente relacionado
contigo y eso significa que resolver ese
problema y salvar el mundo también está
en tus manos
ahora como lo vamos a hacer
sea lo que sea que hagas
en donde estés como lo hagas tú puede
seguir con tu vida y estar salvando el
mundo
como vamos a empezar por ejemplos
sencillos cada día te levantas y lo
primero que hace es obviamente ya
después de ver el teléfono es lavarte
los dientes
y por los estudiantes
pues tú estás pensando en la higiene
bucal la intención es lavarte el diente
pero porque necesitamos usar tres a
cuatro palos de plástico que se van a
tirar se van a contaminar por 500 años o
más y matar a animales y afectarnos
visualmente y nada más estar ahí para
cumplir la misión de lavarnos los
dientes no se les hace un poco ridículo
y existen alternativas si me decían no
la verdad no existían se los acepto yo
tuve que sacar esta línea porque el
méxico no había opciones cuando empecé
con este proceso de tres años hoy en día
ya hay demasiadas opciones en materiales
hermosísimos como el bambú que tú acabas
de usar tu cepillo de dientes y lo puede
enterrar en tu jardín entonces todo este
ciclo de vida después de que tú acabas
de lavarte los dientes ya no tiene
consecuencias negativas
vamos a por ejemplo
cuántos de ustedes es toda la mañana
pasan por un café para llevar
si sacamos la cuenta
de lunes a viernes son 260 días al año
entonces tú personalmente tiras 260
envases al año multiplicado por millones
de personas en el mundo nada más para
tomar café
quiero salvar el mundo
mañana despiértate sal de tu casa compro
un termo y deja de tirar 260 envases tú
solitos
hay dos tendencias en el mundo muy
fuertes que están creciendo y son
extraordinarias una se llama siedo ueis
centrado traducido de cero basura en la
cual toda tu vida adquiere entorno de
nerd genera residuos y hay otra que se
llama minimalismo que habla de tener la
menos cantidad de posiciones posibles
obtener solo las que necesitas ambas son
muy muy buenas pero entiendo también que
hay veces que puede que no tengan la
perseverancia o la motivación necesaria
para vivir sus estilos de vida
entonces sí creo que los podemos cómo
adecuar a la vida de los mortales como
tú como yo que queremos seguir con
nuestra vida pero queremos hacer algo al
respecto entonces qué entendemos por
cero asuma mi lema de vida
es eliminado innecesario porque así como
me ven soy un ambientalista que no tiene
que estar en la calle haciendo huelgas y
peleando me contra los empresarios sino
todo lo contrario busco la manera de
involucrarlos entonces cómo eliminar
innecesario así de sencillo es quitar
esa basura esos productos esas cosas de
nuestra rutina que de verdad nos afectan
a ti mismo porque tú eres media mente
vamos al caso más conocido a nivel
mundial
ahorita escuchamos en todos lados no hay
que consumirlo en la bolsa de plástico
nos regañan muchísimo de que la señora
no lineal agarro bolsas de plástico yo
agarro de cartón y yo soy ecológico
porque agarro cartón y no agarro
plástico pero de hecho hay otro tema que
se lo recomiendo que se llama papel o
plástico que justamente habla de esto si
cambiaste del plástico al cartón
tú estás diciendo con esa acción cuando
tomas esa bolsa de cartón cada vez que
vas al supermercado lo que necesitas
talar un árbol porque produce que el
cartón no es un árbol necesita instalar
un árbol para agarrar el supermercado de
la caja registradora y llevarlo a tu
coche y del coche a tu cocina entonces
tú estás de acuerdo
puede que los saques petróleo pero estás
de acuerdo que está hasta la mona árbol
para una acción de cinco minutos cuando
existen alternativas tan sencillas como
una bolsa de tela que cumple exactamente
el mismo propósito y se puede reutilizar
cientos y miles de veces y aquí está
instalando una planta de algodón o una
planta de yute
para cumplir la misma función no sé si
me doy a entender eso estoy queriendo
decir que pueden seguir con su vida el
medio ambiente son ustedes que pueden
salvar el mundo con acciones tan
sencillas como esta
entonces antes
no se necesita ser radical no se
necesita ser extremistas simplemente se
tiene que llevar acciones pequeñas todos
los días porque de verdad acuérdense que
las empresas las industrias y los
gobiernos nosotros hacemos la demanda
para ellos nosotros dictamos qué es lo
que quiere el mercado entonces si
nosotros cambiamos esa dirección de que
pedimos la oferta también va a cambiar
otro ejemplo que está muy de moda y yo
no puedo con ello llevo a los
restaurantes y los quito se puede
explicar si alguien de ustedes del
restaurantero en qué momento se nos
ocurrió poner un árbol como mantel o qué
función cumple talar un árbol para
ponerlo abajo de tu plato
donde acuerdo
entonces para que vean el poder que
tienen ustedes personalmente les voy a
contar el caso de éxito mío reciente
empecé con mis asesorías hace dos años y
empecé con un blog entonces soy pionera
como co blogger en méxico entonces si me
presentan como like o blogger entonces
tuve la fortuna de conocer un
restaurante a un director de un grupo
restaurante no muy fuerte de mexico y me
dijo yo me quiero meter a todo eso el
medio ambiente pero no sé como dije no
te preocupes yo te ayudo entonces le
vendí mi un asesor ambiental a un grupo
restaurantero cuando yo no sé ni cómo
funcionan los restaurantes ni con chema
ni pan ni te pues tener deficiencia en
los restaurantes y aún así dije
vamos a ver y después de seis meses de
estar investigando todas las
posibilidades ambientales dentro de un
restaurante porque mi lema es eliminar
lo innecesario dije tiene que haber
muchas cosas innecesarias en todo el
proceso del restaurante encontramos
demasiadas áreas de oportunidad y
empezamos con un proyecto del agua
les quiero contar que con este proyecto
del agua el próximo año bueno primero la
prueba piloto fue en diciembre y con un
éxito fue cuatro veces más exitosa de lo
que planeamos entonces ya nos dieron el
plan de expansión a todo nivel nacional
y el próximo año con este proyecto de
agua se van a dejar de consumir más de 3
millones de botellas innecesarias a
nivel nacional cada año
nada más porque me di cuenta que
podíamos eliminar algo innecesario en un
restaurante
aquí voy con todo esto es que medio
ambiente es absolutamente todo
entonces sin medio ambiente es todo
siempre hay un área de oportunidad hay
algo que puedes hacer mejor en tu rutina
y no tienes que inventar el hilo negro
ya existe simplemente es que te des
cuenta y te cuestiones en tus hábitos si
lo que estás haciendo realmente necesita
ser producto si hay alternativas si
puedes hacer mejor las cosas si tú sabes
que estás contaminando si estás
comprando por comprar si de verdad tu
vida está llena de productos
artificiales porque no sólo están
lastimando el medio ambiente te están
lastimando a ti mismo en temas de salud
la consecuencias arreglar esta persona
entonces es muy sencillo ser un
ambientalista es simplemente saber que
el medio ambiente eres tú
por eso
no necesitamos un ambientalista perfecto
necesitamos millones de ambientalistas
imperfectos tomando acción todos los
días lo único que necesita el mundo que
seamos conscientes y que decidamos tomar
acción
todos los días pequeñas y colectivamente
hacer el efecto dominó es por eso yo les
quiero preguntar quién es el medio
ambiente
[Aplausos]